he is my perfect man Emily Blunt and
John Krasinski one of Hollywood's most
beloved celebrity couples to be honest I
know it sounds corny but it's the
greatest collaboration I'll ever have
I'll never work with anybody as talented
and as uh respected as her with over a
decade of marriage under their belts
these two have undeniable chemistry on
screen
where are they
I'll find them
and off he's funny and warm and bright
and confident and
sort of a very emboldening person to be
around because she's actually magic John
and Emily reportedly met in 2008 through
a mutual friend and as Emily tells it
the moment wasn't as romantic as one
might think it's like kind of a sad lame
story you know not sad but it's just
kind of lame I mean we were I was in a
restaurant he was in the restaurant I
was sitting with a mutual friend this is
all romantic comedy this is it this is
it this is Paul and Meredith and my
friend gray goes um oh my God there's my
friend John he was actually sitting with
our friend Justin Thoreau okay and then
uh he abandoned Justin and came over to
come and talk to us he did not eat he
just stood there and made me laugh
fast forward to later that year the two
reportedly had their first date pizza at
John's Apartment John told The Hollywood
Reporter in 2018 that he had to convince
Emily to go out with him but Emily told
the outlet she remembers it differently
and actually asked John out first yeah
it is a date night we try to do one date
night a week at least and uh you know
this isn't a bad one in August 2009 the
actors got engaged nearly a year later
they tied the knot at George Clooney's
estate in Lake Como Italy a few years
into their marriage Emily revealed to
InStyle how meeting John changed her
life quote when I feel the support that
I have from him I feel Invincible
there's someone behind you on your good
days and someone in front of you on your
bad days I know I love her I'm her
biggest fan so first comes love and then
comes marriage and in February 2014 the
two welcomed their first daughter Hazel
Grace and two years later in 26 scene
they expanded their family again with
another little girl Violet in all the
cliches of parenting are true it was
really this new existential magnet that
you feel a draw to your family and I
mean like your parents and you
understand your parents more you
understand your brother's relationship
more you understand even your family
name and with two under two at home
Emily gave E.T a motherhood update
specifically how Hazel was handling
being a big sister she loves it yeah
she's so sweet with her because
sometimes it could go either way oh we
we are relieved that she has yet to try
and suffocate violet yeah and then in
April of 2018 a different kind of
collaboration a movie John directed and
wrote the screenplay for horror flick a
quiet place his Leading Lady Of course
Emily
foreign
[Music]
I said to where we should treat this
movie like we treat our marriage let's
just be honest and talk about everything
as we go rather than waiting and having
it blow up in our face John raved about
working with his wife he said it even
made him see her in a new light the
scene that's on the poster of her in the
bathtub she only did one take and
everyone in the room changed like the
air just left the room no one could
breathe and we called cut and that was
it and and I really did see a whole new
level to my wife it's like she was magic
or something it's like she could
levitate and she never told me it was
really wild to be there when she did
what she did the movie was a box office
Smash and Emily's performance nabbed her
a best supporting actress win at the SAG
Awards so how do you follow up all of
that success
a sequel
and we do collaborate well for sure so
while we wait to see if the lovebirds
team up again in the future we do know
Emily likes to hang on to Sentimental
reminders of her past I'm really
terrible
um old royal blue velvet jacket and I
don't wear it but I
I wore it
um I wore it on John and I's first date
and I have not thrown it out you heard
her right Emily still has a jacket she
wore on her first date with John now
that's love even if it's not exactly on
Trend today but it's such an awful
jacket it sits down I go that is a
terrible jacket
[Music]